it's increasingly difficult getting
around a city in a car so more and more
people are turning to bikes leaders the
thing about bikes sometimes you need to
carry a lot of stuff groceries are your
family that's where this comes in it's
called the edge runner 10e and it's made
by a company called exper cycle it costs
five thousand seven hundred and forty
nine dollars and it's an electric bike
made to carry a lot of stuff we're gonna
find out exactly how much stuff starting
with that keg right there
this honestly looks like it was made on
occasion I guess it's perfect
hold on okay there we go
I don't trust this thing at all
okay so this bike and really probably
any bike is not a way to lug a cake we
figured maybe people would be easier oh
Jesus
the box motor on the edge runner is
state-of-the-art and it's designed to
augment your hub it's four modes of
power don't do the work for you it just
make every one of your pedal strokes
much more powerful the bike is designed
to hold up to 400 pounds including you
and with racks on the front and back
there totally customizable it means that
whether you have a bunch of groceries or
a bunch of people on board you're gonna
have whatever you need so if you're
riding by yourself you can mostly use
Eco mode which is the lowest mode and
that just kind of gives you an extra
boost
every time you pedal the whole point is
that you keep pedaling all the time it
wants you to just keep a consistent pace
of pedaling and you change the help that
you get over time as you go which is
kind of great as opposed to your average
electric bike which either does all the
work for you or doesn't do any work for
you but this is kind of cool it takes a
lot to get going and it takes like a
pretty good steady push to really get
moving but once you're moving it's fine
I think they're terrified behind me but
I'm doing fine
so there are self-driving cars and
hoverboards all trying to make
navigating our daily lives simpler but
the easiest family vehicle I've seen so
far might be this one just a big bike
with a big motor this is better yeah